hey everybody what's up welcome back to
css3 in 30 days today's day number 27
we're gonna be building a drop-down menu
but first I'm gonna be making some more
modifications to my silly looking
microphone here a student of mine
actually suggested that I has nothing to
do with CSS by the way he said in the
box it comes with a large pop filter as
well as this small one I think I'm gonna
try out the big pop filter so give me
one moment how do you take this off so
silly
thanks student for suggesting this to me
now I look even more foolish oh maybe
it's cool back to coding here we go
we're gonna be making a CSS only drop
down menu this is a super simple lesson
and all we're gonna be doing is building
this simple little drop down so I got a
button here that says drop down when I
hover over it BAM we just got three drop
down items normally you'd build this you
know in JavaScript jQuery you and also
CSS but I wanted to show you a really
simple and lightweight version of just
creating a simple css3 drop-down so up
here in our sandbox we've got just a
simple button right here and then three
links so that if none of the styles are
working then at least the links are
visible which is important for
accessibility reasons now let's go over
to our code editor and open up the 27
drop down menu folder folder folder is
what it's called go ahead and download
that open it up in your favorite code
editor and open up the index and sandbox
on CSS as always final about CSS is
there for your reference to make sure
that you're on track and if you have any
issues you can always refer to that so
here we go in the index just a quick at
least show you the markup right here in
the sandbox we've got a div with the
class of drop-down a button within that
div with the class of drop-down menu and
then three links simple simple Sallee
super simple Sam
super simple Sally and Sam sat on super
simple Sally and Sam sat on the sea wall
super simple Sally Sam sat in the
sandbox
Rico open the sandbox and now what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna give it so
we're gonna say drop down and we're
gonna go position:relative and let's go
display:inline-block it's gonna be
important and Zed index let's do 10
I always just use random numbers with
that index have no rhyme or reason to
how I use Zed index all I know is that
if I have if I want one element in front
of the other or make sure it's in front
of everything I'll put a really high
number
so there's your professional strategy
right there
okay now what we want to do is we're
gonna say drop down double underscore
hover what I'm selecting there is simply
the button it has the class of drop down
hover display:inline-block as well I
want to give this a padding of 10 pixels
so we're just making the button look a
little bit nicer here
my fingers are typing a little slower
and clunkier than usual it's a little
chilly down here in the basement I mean
my super high-end premium studio up in
the skyscraper background color
background we're gonna go 3 to 3 and be
40 kind of minds me of ub40 the popular
British reggae band ooh baby I love youi
am a de I want to tell you I love you e
yeah Maddy yeah yeah color white I'm
gonna say cursor:pointer save it let's
check it out
okay so we've got a button here looking
a little bit better but I want that want
that border gone buttons have weird
borders by default in browser so I'm
gonna say button no border
none check it out yeah that's much
better
cool okay so now what we're gonna do
we're gonna start zipping through this a
bit more I'm spending a lot of time
making really high-quality jokes so
let's get back to coding drop down hover
hover that's interesting background
we're gonna say two to two so a little
bit of a dark gray and I'm going to also
select the drop down double underscore
menu and what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna say position absolutes
we're gonna go display:none so this is
the menu itself that's that div at the
class of drop-down underscore double
underscore menu has a sibling to the
button so display:none by default top
100 percent left zero maybe what I
should do is actually not display none
for now so you can actually see it so
I'm gonna just comment that out and I'm
gonna show you what's going on over here
so this is starting to take shape so top
100 percent let me just take that out to
show you what happens
okay nothing so far makes it seem like
this isn't necessary top 100 percent
left 0 min which we're gonna give it a
200 pixel min width background whites as
well and we're gonna say ooh baby no not
that background color 3 2 3 ub40 no be
40 box shadow just giggly today that's
all 0 3 pixel to pixel and then rgba 0 0
0 0.3 so a little bit transparent okay
check it out so far we got a little bit
of a menu here let me take this top 100
percent and left out let's see if it
even really does anything okay it's not
really matter right now but I'm assuming
the reason I just and I did that was to
override any browser specific defaults
that might be messing with it so for
example like top zero percent will be
covering that button the parent which is
the position relative if I do 100
percent it's at the it's 100 percent
down
that that height so it keeps it down
there so that's good okay so now what I
want to do is I want to fix those links
there to make it look like a better list
so I'm gonna say drop-down double
underscore no drop down hover and then
combine that with drop down double
underscore menu okay display:block when
I hover it's gonna be display:block now
remember keep in mind this is normally
not displayed at all but I'm displaying
it as none so the reason why I put that
there is because I'm gonna say display
take away display:none and put that back
in and so now it's not there but when I
hover booms display block so now it
appears so now we're playing with an
actual drop-down menu okay we're gonna
say padding 10 pixels start making this
look a little bit better
text-decoration:none I don't want those
links to have underlines border top
solid one pixel one pixel e OE OE OE 0 e
0 e 0
save it check it out so far looking
better but those list items need to be
oh you know what I didn't do this right
drop down hover final drop down menu is
displayed block but now this is gonna be
drop down menu eh eh there we go so now
we're gonna say those links do that
that's better right there kind of things
are looking a little silly when I say
border:none and also display:block
that's something that we need to do now
it is looking much nicer in fact it's
just about done so now what I want to do
is say drop-down double underscore menu
a and then when you hover over the a
elements background is going to be fo
fo-fo or F 0 F 0 F 0 not fo because you
can't put the letter O in there
f 0 color and then 3 - 3 B 4 T save that
check it out boom
look at that that is a nice tidy little
CSS only drop-down with only about 49
lines of CSS and very minimal markup
just a few lines of HTML so there is
your CSS only drop-down menu thanks for
spending some time with me today coding
up the drop down menu can't wait to see
you and a number 28 and don't forget
[Music]
[Music]